indudablemente es un momento solemne no
son 20 años de aniversario bueno
obviamente los esfuerzos de seguridad se
han redoblado aquí en la ciudadanía
mayor que yo creo que la amenaza externa
no lo es tanto obviamente estamos
hablando de temas de seguridad internas
pero que obviamente ocurre en cualquier
ciudad incluso el departamento de
policía de la ciudad no mayor ha dicho
que los índices de criminalidad han
bajado este año comparado con otros con
otros meses de este 2001 pero no creo
que haya nada de qué preocuparse me
parece que el momento lo amerita y bueno
estamos aquí salvos por lo menos no ver
lo que sí que está claro es que aquel
día cambiaron muchas cosas pero el
cambio la manera en la que nos sentimos
seguros o la manera en la que afrontamos
la seguridad bueno obviamente como decía
la mitad incluso yo creo que el factor
del miedo también influyó mucho y
todavía lo sigue haciendo yo creo que
todavía quedan frases como por ejemplo
la de si ve algo diga algo que fue una
frase que se veía y se leía en todas
partes obviamente el dejar una maleta
descuidada o cualquier artefacto que
podría ser sospechoso pues ya era motivo
de alarma aquí en la ciudad de mayor
todas existe estrés postraumático muchas
de las personas que vinieron a rescatar
no solamente bomberos policías sino
personas del común que querían ayudar a
limpiar los escombros todavía enfrentan
graves desafíos de salud y eso todavía
lo hemos visto personas que han
desarrollado enfermedades
cardiorrespiratorias sin fin todavía
vemos las secuelas de lo que fue ese
fatídico día hace 20 años no tenemos
también las secuelas en el urbanismo del
propio en nueva york se ha levantado
bolardos hay muchísima mayor presencia
policial los controles en el metro son
cada vez mayores incluso a la hora de
viajar y quitarnos los cinturones los
para todo eso realmente se ha quedado ya
había venido para quedarse y todavía
podría incrementar más bueno dependiendo
a quién le preguntes porque obviamente
hay partes del mundo en donde bueno ya
ni siquiera es requerido quitarse los
zapatos bueno todavía en eeuu se tiene
que hacer indudablemente yo creo que las
las medidas de seguridad han sido
reguladas incluso cuando tú vas al
aeropuerto existe un programa que se
llama el tee ezeiza que las personas que
puedan transitar libremente para la
puerta pero tienen que digamos rendir
seguridad información identidad con lo
cual eso también nos lleva a otro punto
de lo que ocurrió en el 9/11 que es que
tanta información estamos proveyendo al
gobierno que tanta privacidad tenemos
precisamente con el advenimiento de la
nueva tecnología los teléfonos celulares
el hecho de que bueno un montón de
controversia con el tema del acto
patriota que es un tema que no vamos a
tocar pero es un tema de seguridad en
fin yo creo que aquí también el tema
además del miedo también es el tema de
la privacidad de que tanta digamos que
tanta intimidad podemos tener en el
sentido de que tanta información
proveemos al gobierno y eso es algo que
también han surgido después del 9/11
precisamente ahí se abre otra brecha de
seguridad que es la llamada
ciberseguridad es otra otro otro
apartado al que nos enfrentamos también
en estos momentos que después de 20 años
nos llega como algo completamente nuevo
pero estamos preparados para hacerle
frente bueno mira es un arma de doble
filo que si luego obviamente la
tecnología ha evolucionado desde hace 20
años y aún así hace 20 años pues ya
obviamente estábamos entrando una nueva
era tecnológica con el white uke y el
dow la entrada a un nuevo milenio a
nuevas tecnologías pero ha sido de doble
filo en el sentido de que incluso
también los grupos terroristas que
surgieron del 9/11 como es el caso de
isis como es el caso de al qaeda incluso
reclutaron jóvenes por medio de internet
y todavía lo siguen haciendo de hecho ni
siquiera dentro de la zona de medio
oriente que era la zona obviamente donde
eeuu llegó a invadir sino incluso
interno aquí aquí hubo muchos jóvenes
saliendo de eeuu que fueron a ser
reclutados por isis y que fueron incluso
digamos atraídos precisamente por las
fuentes de información online así que yo
creo que obviamente ya no hay revés y
probablemente yo creo que esto va a
seguir siendo una tendencia en el tema
de tecnológico seguirán seguiremos
viendo nuevas tecnologías y a medida que
surjan nuevas tecnologías como facebook
como twitter como snap chat como texto
que surgieron precisamente después del
9/11 todas esas tecnologías pues yo creo
que el gobierno tiene que ir al al mismo
paso en que va avanzando la tecnología y
nosotros también adquirir conciencia de
que tanta información estamos proveyendo
de que tanto que tanta seguridad estamos
teniendo en nuestros hogares obviamente
todo producto de lo que fue
probablemente yo creo que el primer
bueno no sé si poner los reality pero sí
en la primera vez que vimos en vivo y en
directo un ataque semejantes magnitudes
que yo creo que ha quedado en la memoria
de muchos de nosotros que ángel ha
quedado en la memoria y precisamente en
un día como hoy en una fecha tan redonda
este vigésimo aniversario que como
decíamos coincide con esa salida de las
tropas de afganistán aquí muchos
estadounidenses con los que hemos podido
hablar lo que nos récords a lo que nos
cuentan es que vuelven esos fantasmas
del pasado vuelve ese miedo coincidiendo
con este aniversario y muchos de ellos
incluso nos decían que no van a pasar
por esta zona hoy por lo que bueno por
miedo por respeto por muchas otras
cuestiones pero lo que sí que vemos es
que han cerrado muchísimas calles hay
todo un dispositivo de seguridad en
marcha con todos los cuerpos policiales
de este país poniendo los ojos aquí
verdad bueno imagínate para llegar acá
también un esquema de seguridad y tienes
que andar con precaución porque
obviamente viendo el cuerpo policial que
hay pues te intimida un poco no pero yo
creo que todo ha surgido dentro de la
normalidad y lo que tú dices yo creo que
lo que estamos viendo al fondo de
nosotros a través de nosotros es un es
un testamento de que eeuu a pesar de que
fue un momento tan difícil y tan tan
como vuelve mencionó fuimos testigos
indirectos y algunos testigos de
excepción yo creo que el hecho de
levantar nuevas estructuras de crear un
monumento de crear un museo de tener un
árbol para muchos que no saben hay un
árbol que se quedo incólume después de
los ataques una estructura una escultura
que fue trasladada a otra área de la
ciudad que aunque recibe algunos daños
todavía permanece de pie habla
precisamente es un testimonio de lo que
es este país realmente de lo que es
nueva york realmente nueva york es una
ciudad que a pesar de haber recibido un
golpe fuerte además de lo de arlington
ido de pensilvania eso decía que se
mantiene en constante movimiento y lo
digo yo porque yo vivo aquí es decir es
una ciudad que no se detiene no nos
detuvimos con los huracanes ni siquiera
con los fenómenos naturales que hemos
tenido en los últimos en las últimas
semanas es una ciudad en constante
evolución en constante cambio es una
ciudad que no se detiene y yo creo que
lo que estamos viendo al fondo o al
quien lo que es también de los
televidentes es precisamente eso es no
solamente el levantar una estructura que
es la estructura más alta del hemisferio
occidental sino también es un testamento
de qué de lo que hemos visto pues hay
que seguir hay que seguir viviendo hay
que hay que seguir innovando hay que
seguir evolucionando y de eso se trata
precisamente el espíritu de lo que es
una ciudad como la ciudad nueva york'
fue capaz de renacer de ese terrible
atentado que vivió aquí y hoy 20 años
después de este recuerdo sigue muy vivo
pero los newyorkinos se sienten muy
orgullosos de haber conseguido salir
adelante